hi everyone can you hear me yeah perfect
um so hi everyone welcome to my talk um
there's no doubt that pice Park has
become extremely popular over the last
couple of years
and it's now a go to data processing
framework I've as you heard before like
Romeo had a different opinion but like
for me it's still the main one to use
and so we're going to talk about PI
spark today but let's first talk briefly
about me so my name is Semak and I work
for a company called market finance as a
data engineer so we are a london-based
FinTech company helping UK businesses
get access to a wide range of financial
solutions like invoice finance and loans
so part of my my job there is to
maintain our spark PI spark jobs so we
basically use AWS and we have our data
like on on as free so we use spark to
transform the raw data is free and save
it back so today I'm going to show you
how we structured our price per
application so it is to deploy maintain
and share with other developers I'm not
going to talk about how to write code
and or for example how to optimize the
jobs in fact the jobs that I'm going to
show here I'm extremely simple and I'm
going to show the ETL jobs here but I
know that other people here might
actually be interested in Marshall
learning code which I believe it also
can be used using this structure so
first why do we actually need this kind
of talk at all so the answer is on this
image we're so SPARC and it's basically
cluster computing system which means
that in require it runs on a cluster of
machines and we need to deploy our our
code to all the nodes of the cluster and
in order to run it in case of single
machine we would probably deploy our
code there install dependencies using
people rather package manager and then
run our application code we spark we
need to find a way to actually run that
on a cluster level so here comes the
submit script to help and the spark
summit is a part of a spark and
distribution and it's used to launch
applications on a cluster it takes care
of setting up and distributing the code
for us so during this talk I'm going to
show a couple of parks emit options that
can be used to launch our Python
application and in the jobs that I'm
going to show here I fused movie lens
data set which has data about the movies
and it's ratings so here we have the
head of the movies file and two things
here I would like to notice here the
first one is that the title column
contains both tighter and the year and
that the genre column contains the pipe
separate lists so these are going to be
our two first jobs that we're going to
use here so the first one is going to
create two columns title and year and
the other one which is going to have a
one row per movie and the other one
sorry is going to have a multiple rows
per one movie ID we each with one genre
movie so here we have our first version
of movies dope as I said before very
simple code it has less than 20 lines
and what it actually does it creates a
spark session right draw data from a
moon movie CSV file transforms it like I
said before to
title and here and then saves the data
to up in a pocket for mod to some
location and this is the other drop
which looks very similar and this is our
structure of our application so there
are two files there so now in order to
run this application and let's say
movies job on the cluster we are going
to run our spark summit script using the
movies file and so as I said before very
simple application and it actually does
what we want it but does it's the way
that we want it not sure so going back
to our movies job again first thing that
I'm going to change here is there are
some values that I'm going that we want
to export from this file to a separate
file and the first thing that comes to
mind actually might be application name
but most importantly I believe input and
output Puffs should be extracted to a
separate file so I'm going to create a
separate config file which I'm going to
use and it looks like this only has this
free entries up name source data puffin
output data puff and now I need to
update my movies pi drop so what I'm
going to do here is I'm going to read
this file and create a dictionary
confectionary and then use this
configuration area in a couple of places
to read for example the puffs that we
use here so we already see that we could
click up is a bit more configurable but
what we've done now with another file to
our application
and so we have this config find here and
now we actually to find a way to send
this file to a cluster so we can do that
using the files option from the spark
some script and which can be used to add
non Python files to our to our cluster
in our case it's a configuration file
okay so again coming back to our movies
file now we can see that we have the
duplicated code in this file
especially this like a boilerplate code
at the top of the file where we create a
config object and sparks session and
this code is not duplicated in all of
our jobs we have only two but in the
production application probably it's
more so we are going to create a
separate file that is going to contain
this code and going to be treated as an
entry point application so what I've
done I've got a main Python file which
now as you can see it requires an input
argument jobs drop which tells the
application which job to run and then it
has this boilerplate code here so it
creates a config object and sparks
session imports relevant job module that
we need and runs the Mazda module using
the run job function and since there the
spark config and sparks session and the
config object so in order to do that to
run the main file I also needed to
update movies job so I've separated this
code into multiple functions so we have
an function to read the data from csv
transform the date download it save the
data to a pocket and to of course
and job function that does that's within
the main the main file and it's it's
used to run the job so now how our
structure looks like we have a new jobs
package directory in our app which
contains our jobs and we also have the
main file so now in order to run our job
on the cluster we need to first we now
we need to run the main file and specify
the job name and as a top argument and
we have a new option and which is PI
files we now add our jobs as a zipped
file to the cluster but what happened
now is that we need to manually zip the
top directory in order to add it to the
cluster so what we are going to do we
are going to use make file basically
make utility so make is a utility and
that just make files to define this set
of tasks that needs to be executed I
believe it was created to build C code
but has a wider application now so they
are using basically so as you can see
here what we are doing is we are going
to create a new dist directory in our
application and copy all of the files
there and also we are actually creating
this job zip
so now after running the make built
comment we are presented with this
application structure
and we can see that there is a new this
directory which now basically contains
everything that we need to deliver to
our cluster so it basically separates
our code from like what we need to cast
around what's probably worth mentioning
here is that this this directory has
been added to a grid ignore so it's not
going to be added to our repository as
basically it contains the the copy of
all the other file the other files that
already exist there and here's the Kenda
parks emit comment but this time we have
the zip file from our make file so again
coming back to our movies began now we
decided to that we want to separate the
data operations data files logic from
the domain logic so in this case we have
this two columns that we create here and
we probably would like to separate this
logic from this so what we are going to
do is we are going I'm going to create
the UDF functions so video functions are
the user-defined functions that work on
a column level and on a data frame so
here I've created a UDF PI file which
contains these two functions get movie
title and get movie here and it
registers these two idiots out of these
functions very simple so now I need to
use these UDF's in our job so here we
can see that I'm importing the UDF's
module that I've added inside the shirt
package so basically inside the shared
directory in our up and I'm using this
two functions here
and again our sophistication structure
we have the shared directory and we need
to add this one more zip file to our
make file and after running it we have
this additional file in our structure so
now we in order to add this to our
cluster again we use the same options
before PI files so and we added a second
file on the list here but coming back to
our UDF's
file and maybe we've decided that
slicing the string is not the best
option in this case and we want to use
some other option so I've decided to use
a third-party package to run that so I
go I'm going to use a parse package in
this case so this is the new version and
as you can see I'm importing the parts
package and then using parsing this
title column using the template defined
here so now the issue is that the parts
package does not a part of a standard
library and we need to install it
separately so we need to requirements
txt file to our application
which contains the packages that we need
and it's versions so in our case it's
only a part bucket at this time and we
are going to add this to our make file
so now we we install the third-party
packages inside our this directory in
this case it's going to be lips
directory which is going to contain all
of the third-party packages and I think
it actually might be a good idea to Rose
a docker image to do that because like
some so we are fair that
the version that we install for example
okole is actually going to work on our
cluster so we should probably use this
like docker image that is compatible
with our cluster and at the end we have
again zipping the libs directory into
ellipse zip file and it's worth
mentioning here that as opposed to
shared director and job directory in
here we need to zip the content of the
directory not the actual directory
itself because we want to use the
package inside directly by calling it
part's not the Lipstadt part so after
running this this is how our structure
looks like and again we have a new zip
point here and again the from file on
the list at the end of the PI files so
as you can see our application actually
changed a bit from this beginning but
there's probably one very important
thing missing still I think that it
probably should start with or at least
edit a lot earlier in the process anyone
fancy you guys yeah
so I'm in this case so we're going to
add some tests to our application and
here we have a test file that is going
to test our movies job and one of the
tests there so what I'm using a I'm
using a spy test as a testing package
testing engine but on top of that I'm
also using the PI test spark package
that comes with this park session feet
fixture built in which basically mmm
simplifies the tests for us
we already have this building in our
test engine and because of the pipe
because the PI test doesn't have the
option to assert dataframes equality I'm
using the pandas testing package wave
it's a third frame equal method and I
also have apart from that file I also
have another file that is going to test
our unit tests that are going to test
our mobile UDF's and here we have the
version of our make file after adding
the tests so we have a new to two new
receipts in this file so now when we run
the make comment berm a comment or all
make all for example we are going to run
our tests first so we are sure that
everything's going to work as expected
or at least we reduce the uncertainty of
that and here's our application
structure at the end and as I've
mentioned before we have the dist
directory which is the one that is going
to be deployed to our cluster so how to
do that in our case we basically use
terraformers that our infrastructure is
code tool and we use a CI CD pipelines
basically to to deliver this code to our
as free bucket where then this code is
going the puffs to as free buckets are
going to be used by this box and within
our jobs yeah
so now going back to the last quote of
the talk the code is read much more
often than it's written which basically
means that the quality of the code is
important and as so the first version of
the application had two files as opposed
to make more than ten at the end and the
final application actually does exactly
the same it's it's the same data from
the same place it transform it the same
way and it saves the data to the same
location so basically does the same but
if the location of the input-output data
is going to change then we only need to
change our confiar we don't need to
change all of our jobs if the domain
logic changes like for example we've
changed the way how we calculate the
columns we also change that only in UDF
functions not inside the jobs we also
other tests to our application which
makes it more secure to deploy to
production and we also created like this
main file which actually removed all of
the boilerplate code to a separate file
which now makes it easier to create a
new jobs so in my opinion even if the
application at the end does exactly the
same I believe that it does it more in a
more configurable way it's easier to
read and less painful to deploy thank
you
so basically has this applications so if
you explained but yeah you are yes yes
okay yeah so basically what happens here
is the windows and I'm going to and then
I'm going to so in this case what
happens here the inside and then we so
we required for the application and some
time yeah that's a good question I don't
know actually this is how this is how we
write it and yeah probably we should we
should change it but this is how it
currently currently looks like
next question anyone
it's a simple one
what AWS service do you use to execute
your spark jobs yeah we currently use
glue jobs but we also we've also run
this code on a EMR but we currently use
a good jobs so basically define all of
the jobs in in terraform the jobs and
how do you configure then your clusters
because you need to know how many worker
nodes master nodes and all that so there
must be a lot of infrastructure behind
this we basically you jobs so basically
like a glue this is like a managed AWS
service right but of course we can like
a tweak it a bit by like setting some of
the some of the pipe some of the spice
spark options inside the inside the glue
job exactly the same as running this
park submit comments right so the same
as like I farted there I kept files in
PI files you can also define memory for
example on a cluster or number of nodes
yeah but of course the glue jobs they
have some limitations in this case so
but actually we like I said we also run
it on an earmark cluster but for our
purposes it was actually easier for us
to run it on a job is that because the
jobs were small or that they were more
frequent less yeah we have like 200 of
jobs like that where I can very small
yeah that's very small but yeah
so I had a more general question about
debugging information so I know that if
you run on a notebook for example which
is that's sort of the go-to for a lot of
people you get a lot of information if
there's an error especially for a lot of
rolling parts like say you you're using
park' files you're just hosting on s3
but I actually really like your approach
and kind of the canonical classic way
you submit jobs to a cluster and etc but
I'm curious about what sort of debugging
information you get pact with so many
rolling parts for example with docker
with actually the job submission to
cluster where you're not using a
notebook and things like this are you
able to set up some environments very
easily say in IntelliJ or Sam or
whatever where you have easy to access
information if when there's an error
when you're debugging it'd be the error
on docker or on M on the Amazon side or
on just the code side in general say for
the job actually running in some some
faulty Python code that's been written
so I think that actually a couple a
couple things here um but probably
answering your question is that we are
probably not good at that yet so
basically we we use as it does is runs
on AWS we use a cloud watch where to
like check the locks of like glue jobs
so spark logs but we also have the
elasticsearch cluster which basically
but we only store log they're like the
start of the job end of the job and like
error or something like that so
basically I don't need to make compare
that at the end of the day we have like
200 that finished and 200 that started
or something like that so so that's it
and we also use a CI CD pipeline and we
have some tests there right so if for
example something will will fail in in
this in this make file we would see it
there right so see I see I see a pipe I
would probably fail on
unlike a pre-deployment test or at least
on death before running the co2
production and we will stop the pipeline
in some words if I understand correctly
it's just a more cumbersome coding it's
still more let's say difficult as it
currently stands coding with this
infrastructure then it's like you say
for example we're debugging a single
patent just for simplicity a single
Python file that was loading some CSV
that was like 10 megabytes yeah of
course question is anyone I don't see
thank you thank you
[Applause]